can you just play a video that like you  would jerk off to what is your time I'm  definitely very into Asian men I'm Asian  can we tug  boy immediately passes on her oh  boy  it's a bigger girl saying I love anime I  love Asian dudes all this stuff this  guy's gonna want to hear the second they  touch they give them the chance to get  they understand that we love watching  rejection they looked at the big girl in  her life she's not gonna make it far in  the second people see her they're the  ones that are sexist and fat folks what  would you do you just kind of going to  feel bad for five days just because you  feel bad you go on a date not a meal but  uh coffee we could do coffee what is she  gonna eat you said you want to take her  to Sea World Park I would never make her  go in the pool and open her mouth and  throw a little fish in her mouth I  wouldn't do that he would have took that  off and just be like  [Laughter]